Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I was 11 when the war started. If I honestly sort out my memories and disregard what I have learned since, I must admit that nothing in the whole war moved me so deeply as the loss of the Titanic had done a few years earlier. This comparatively petty disaster shocked the whole world, and the shock has not quite died away even yet. I remember the terrible detailed accounts read out at the breakfast table
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。战争开始时我才11岁。如果我诚实地梳理自己的记忆，抛开后来所学的一切，我必须承认，整个战争期间没有任何事能像几年前泰坦尼克号沉没那样让我感触如此之深。这场相对较小的灾难震惊了全世界，而这种震撼至今尚未完全消散。我记得早餐桌上读到的那些可怕的细节报道。
in those days. It was a common habit to read the newspaper aloud, and I remember that in all the long list of horrors, the one that most impressed me was that at the last, the Titanic suddenly upended and sank bow foremost so that the people clinging to the stern were lifted no less than 300 feet into the air before they plunged into the abyss. It gave me a sinking sensation in the belly, which I can still all but feel. Nothing in the war ever gave me quite that sensation. So that, Dominic, was top man of the people, George Orwell, in My Country Right or Left. And he wrote that in 1940, which of course was the middle of the Second World War. But the war there, he's talking about the First World War. And he is saying that nothing in the Great War, as it was known, impacted him quite
在那个年代，大声朗读报纸是一种常见的习惯。我记得在所有长长的恐怖名单中，最让我印象深刻的是，在最后时刻，泰坦尼克号突然船尾朝天，船头先沉入水中，以至于紧紧抓住船尾的人被抬高到离水面至少300英尺的空中，然后坠入深渊。这让我的腹部产生了一种下沉的感觉，至今我几乎还能感受到。战争中没有任何事给我带来过那种感觉。所以，多米尼克，那是人民的领袖乔治·奥威尔在《我的国家，无论对错》中所写的。他写于1940年，当然那是第二次世界大战中期。但他所说的战争是第一次世界大战。他说，在所谓的“大战”中，没有任何事能像
like the shock of something that had happened two years before the outbreak of the First World War, namely the sinking of the Titanic. Yeah, isn't that extraordinary? But actually, it's a really interesting sign of how deeply the loss of the Titanic affected people in the 1910s. And now in our collective consciousness, Tom, the sinking of the Titanic is generally treated as a kind of precursor to the First World War, isn't it? Yeah. It's a kind of metaphor. Yeah, it's a metaphor. It's the sense in which industrial society was so rich and powerful,
两年前泰坦尼克号沉没带来的震撼那样影响他。是的，这难道不非凡吗？但这实际上是一个非常有趣的迹象，表明泰坦尼克号的沉没在1910年代对人们的影响有多深。汤姆，现在在我们的集体意识中，泰坦尼克号的沉没通常被视为第一次世界大战的一种前奏，不是吗？是的。这是一种隐喻。是的，这是一种隐喻。它意味着工业社会曾经如此富有和强大，
and it was heading for an inevitable smash. Crash. Yeah. So you might say that Europe was a great ship steaming towards the iceberg of industrial warfare. But that's what people have said since the 1910s itself. Yeah. So there's the great line in The Onion announcing the sinking of the Titanic. World's largest metaphor hits iceberg. So I think that we should come to all these in due course. And we should also come to the way that the Titanic has
却正走向一场不可避免的粉碎。崩溃。是的。所以你可能会说，欧洲就像一艘巨大的船，正全速驶向工业战争的冰山。但这是自1910年代以来人们一直这么说的。是的。所以《洋葱报》有一句名言宣布泰坦尼克号沉没：世界最大的隐喻撞上了冰山。所以我认为我们应该在适当的时候讨论所有这些。我们也应该谈谈泰坦尼克号
been shown in film as well. Because actually Orwell's describing how the stern upends and people cling onto the edge and then it just plummets down. In the 1997 film with Kate Winslet and Leonardo DiCaprio, that is the bit that stuck in my mind. And I actually found it so upsetting and traumatic that I never watched the film again until yesterday evening I watched it. Tom, and did you enjoy it? I really enjoyed it, but I still found it traumatic for reasons that perhaps we'll come to when we talk about that. But I think that for now, in this episode and the next, let's park all that metaphorical stuff, let's park all the way that the Titanic has been
在电影中的呈现方式。因为奥威尔描述了船尾如何翘起，人们紧紧抓住边缘，然后它就直坠下去。在1997年凯特·温斯莱特和莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥主演的电影中，那是我脑海中挥之不去的片段。我实际上觉得它太令人不安和痛苦了，以至于我再也没有看过这部电影，直到昨天晚上我才又看了一遍。汤姆，你喜欢它吗？我真的很喜欢，但我仍然觉得它很痛苦，原因也许我们在讨论那部电影时会提到。但我想现在，在这一集和下一集里，让我们先把那些隐喻性的东西放在一边，让我们先把泰坦尼克号在
reimagined over the century and more that's followed it. And look at it as an episode within history because it is brilliant, isn't it? It is. As a kind of opening up huge vistas of historical analysis and all kinds of topics. It is. It's one of those stories that actually until we sort of sat down to research it, I had rather dismissed. I think because of the film, I'd seen it as a sort of slushy melodrama. sort of Julian Fellow's The Downton Abbey Guy. He did his own miniseries about it. And I always thought for that reason, oh God, out of slight snobbery, actually, I thought the Titanic is beneath me. And some of our listeners may be thinking that, by the way.
过去一个多世纪里被重新想象的方式放在一边。把它看作历史中的一个片段，因为它确实很精彩，不是吗？确实如此。它开启了历史分析的巨大视野和各种各样的话题。确实。这是一个故事，实际上在我们坐下来研究它之前，我曾有些轻视它。我想是因为那部电影，我把它看作一种多愁善感的通俗剧。有点像朱利安·费罗斯，那个《唐顿庄园》的家伙。他自己也制作过关于它的迷你剧。出于一点势利，我一直认为泰坦尼克号对我来说太肤浅了。顺便说一句，我们的一些听众可能也在这么想。
But I completely agree with you. I think it is one of the best topics we've ever done on The Rest is History because it's a window into so many things, into kind of late Gilded Age New York, into the sectarianism and the political violence of Belfast, the technological advancements of the early 20th century, class, immigration, all of these kinds of things. And also I thought, fascinatingly, the ambivalent relationship between Britain and America at the point where kind of not just global and industrial leadership, but maritime leadership is starting to shift from Britain to America. Absolutely. And that's the focus really of what we want to talk about today, isn't it? Yes. Yeah. And there's actually a German dimension to this as well, which is why it is quite a nice prelude to the Great War, because there's an Anglo-German rivalry that's very important in the story of Titanic. So yeah, so the background, the origins, I think it's a story of three men in particular. So they're J.P. Morgan, Bruce Ismay, and William Pirrie. And two cities in particular, New York City
但我完全同意你的看法。我认为这是我们在《历史的余味》中做过的最好的主题之一，因为它是一扇通往许多事物的窗口，通往镀金时代末期的纽约，通往贝尔法斯特的宗派主义和政治暴力，通往20世纪初的技术进步、阶级、移民，所有这些。而且我还认为，令人着迷的是，英国和美国之间那种矛盾的关系，在那个不仅是全球和工业领导地位，而且是海上领导地位开始从英国向美国转移的时刻。绝对是这样。这确实是我们今天想谈的重点，不是吗？是的。而且这实际上还有一个德国维度，这就是为什么它是大战的一个很好的序幕，因为在泰坦尼克号的故事中，英德竞争非常重要。所以，背景、起源，我认为这是三个人的故事。他们是J.P.摩根、布鲁斯·伊斯梅和威廉·皮里。还有两个城市，纽约
and Belfast. And I guess we should start right at the very top, as it were, Tom, of the pyramid. And that is the man who comes to embody the ruthless empire-building capitalism of late 19th, early 20th century America, of the Gilded Age, what is now seen as the arrogance and hubris. And it's a man whose name has become one of the most recognisable kind of capitalist brands, J.P. Morgan. Yeah, because it's still a bank to this day, isn't it? Absolutely. So the US at the end of the 19th, early 20th century, it's the China of its day. It's the coming power.
和贝尔法斯特。我想我们应该从金字塔的最顶端开始，汤姆。那就是那个体现了19世纪末20世纪初美国镀金时代无情的帝国建设资本主义的人，现在被视为傲慢和狂妄的化身。他的名字已经成为最广为人知的资本主义品牌之一，J.P.摩根。是的，因为直到今天它仍然是一家银行，不是吗？绝对是。所以19世纪末20世纪初的美国，就是当年的中国。它是正在崛起的强权。
It has fought this war in 1898 and gained the Philippines and Puerto Rico from Spain. And there's a sense of enormous self-confidence and swagger about America, about American capitalism in 1912. And the man who embodies this is John Pierpont Morgan. So he was educated in Switzerland, wasn't he? And he's a very grim kind of doer man. But his uncle, am I right? Have you seen this? His uncle wrote Jingle Bells.
它在1898年打赢了那场战争，从西班牙手中获得了菲律宾和波多黎各。1912年的美国，以及美国资本主义，有一种巨大的自信和傲慢。体现这一点的人就是约翰·皮尔庞特·摩根。他是在瑞士受的教育，对吧？他是一个非常严厉的人。但他叔叔，我没记错吧？你见过这个吗？他叔叔写了《铃儿响叮当》。
Yeah. It's like Kennedy's grandfather being the first person to put the lights on a public Christmas tree. Yeah. It's one of those bizarre kind of unexpected intersections
是的。这就像肯尼迪的祖父是第一个在公共圣诞树上挂灯的人一样。是的。这是美国高层政治与美国流行文化之间
between high American politics and American popular culture. But I mean, you say he's doer, but he is a cultured man. Oh, yes, he is. Yeah. He speaks French and German. He hangs out in Rome. He's goter, but he is a cultured man. Oh yes, he is. Yeah. He speaks French and German. He hangs out in Rome. He's got Savile Row tailors, all this kind of thing.
那种离奇的、意想不到的交集之一。但我的意思是，你说他严厉，但他是一个有文化的人。哦，是的，他是。他会说法语和德语。他在罗马闲逛。他有萨维尔街的裁缝，诸如此类的事情。
Yeah, it's true. He's very interested in European culture. But in a slightly joyless way though, Tom, don't you think? Yes. Well, the kind of accumulative way, because European culture becomes something to invest in and to buy and to take over the Atlantic. And this is, of course, one of the aspects of why there are so many American millionaires on the Titanic. He's not alone in doing that. It was like a character from a Henry James novel. So Henry James was actually writing during this period, these novels about very rich Americans going to Europe and collecting things, collecting people, sort of paying homage to the cultural achievements
是的，这是真的。他对欧洲文化非常感兴趣。但汤姆，你不觉得这有点缺乏乐趣吗？是的。这是一种积累的方式，因为欧洲文化变成了可以投资、购买并接管大西洋的东西。当然，这也是泰坦尼克号上有那么多美国百万富翁的原因之一。他并不是唯一这样做的人。他就像亨利·詹姆斯小说中的一个角色。亨利·詹姆斯实际上是在这一时期写作，这些小说讲述了非常有钱的美国人去欧洲收集东西、收集人，向意大利或法国的文化成就致敬，
of Italy or France. But also looting it. I mean, not looting it, but I mean, buying it up. He's absolutely one of these people. Now he's made his money back in the US by basically investing in modernity. So he's made his money by investing in railroads and streetcars and all of these kinds of things. But he's also, he is seen as the personification of Wall Street's new importance in the US and world economy.
但也掠夺它。我的意思是，不是掠夺，而是买下它。他绝对是这些人之一。现在他在美国通过投资现代性赚了钱。他通过投资铁路、有轨电车和所有这些东西赚了钱。但他也被视为华尔街在美国和世界经济中新重要性的化身。
So he had intervened effectively to bail out the United States after the panic of 1893. I mean, to cut a very long story short, he'd effectively sold gold to the US government in return for a massive bond. So he had saved the US treasury. There was no central bank in the US at this point. So he basically is the United States' central titanic about him when he really gets to work. And that adjective titanic is capitalised. So the sense of Morgan being titanic is part of the kind of the common vocabulary that is used to describe him again and again and again.
所以他在1893年恐慌后有效地干预了美国，以救助美国。长话短说，他实际上是以债券为抵押向美国政府出售黄金。所以他拯救了美国财政部。当时美国没有中央银行。所以他基本上就是美国的中央银行。当他真正开始工作时，人们称他为“泰坦尼克号”般的摩根。那个形容词“泰坦尼克”是大写的。所以摩根是“泰坦尼克”的这种感觉，是反复用来描述他的常用词汇的一部分。
Because this is the first point really where people are talking about these gigantic business tycoons, more powerful than any government. You know, these are not the industrialists of the kind of industrial revolution. They are bigger than that. They are people who are, as you said, collecting art, as Morgan is. So the people talk about them as like the Caesars or the Emperors. But they're also collecting companies. So Morgan is the king of what are called at the time the trusts. So these are huge merged conglomerates. Monopolies.
因为这是人们第一次真正谈论这些比任何政府都强大的巨大商业大亨。你知道，这些不是工业革命时期的工业家。他们比那更伟大。他们是像你所说的，像摩根那样收集艺术品的人。所以人们谈论他们就像谈论凯撒或皇帝一样。但他们也在收集公司。所以摩根是当时所谓的“托拉斯”之王。这些是巨大的合并企业集团。垄断企业。
Monopolies. The most famous one is US Steel. So he had bought out Andrew Carnegie. And Andrew Carnegie, again, is a kind of representative figure, perhaps of an earlier age because he comes from Scotland in 1848. So he is emigrating out on the age where, you know, Atlantic crossings are really, really tough. There's a kind of definitely a Logan Roy quality to him. I mean, maybe there's a kind of deliberate allusion to that, a Scot going out and making it big in the United States. And he owns this vast steel company and Morgan buys him out, gives him $240 million so that in paper terms, Carnegie becomes the richest man in the world. But of course, Morgan as the man who now controls this,
垄断。最著名的是美国钢铁公司。所以他收购了安德鲁·卡内基。而安德鲁·卡内基，同样是一个代表性人物，也许是更早时代的代表，因为他1848年从苏格兰来到美国。所以他是在大西洋航行还非常非常艰难的时代移民过来的。他身上绝对有一种洛根·罗伊（Logan Roy）的特质。我的意思是，也许这是一种故意的影射，一个苏格兰人去美国闯出了一片天。他拥有这家庞大的钢铁公司，摩根买下了他，给了他2.4亿美元，所以从纸面上看，卡内基成了世界上最富有的人。但当然，摩根作为现在控制这一切的人，
I mean, he's the most titanic figure of all. And there's another kind of intriguing figure involved in that, isn't there? In the buyout of Carnegie and the founding of US Steel. There's a man called Peter Widener, who again is a kind of archetypal Gilded Age figure. So he's from Philadelphia. He begins as a butcher's boy. He very rapidly sets up this huge chain of butcher's shops across the United States. Then he invests in trams. So he kicks off with the Philadelphia Traction Company, and then he gets traction companies and cities across the whole of the us he's literally picking up traction tom he's literally picking up traction very good and he like morgan it ends up obscenely rich invests in art he's spotted by
我的意思是，他是所有人中最泰坦尼克式的人物。还有一个引人入胜的人物参与其中，不是吗？在收购卡内基和创立美国钢铁公司时。有一个人叫彼得·怀德纳，他也是镀金时代的一个典型人物。他来自费城。他最初是一个屠夫学徒。他很快就在美国各地建立了一个庞大的肉铺连锁店。然后他投资了电车。所以他从费城牵引公司开始，然后他在美国各地的城市都获得了牵引公司。他简直是在捡牵引力，汤姆。他简直是在捡牵引力。非常好。像摩根一样，他最终富得流油，投资艺术品。他被
henry adams who's kind of very much an old school bostonian brahmin collecting art in paris adams calls him an odious old american and his son and indeed grandson will follow the tradition of going across the atlantic to france to collect art and then coming back and they may feature later in the story dominic exactly and they of course come back on the Titanic, Tom. So Morgan has been collecting companies. U.S. Steel is his most successful, the most famous. So U.S. Steel was 1901. At the same point, 1901 to 2, he decides to extend his dominion to the seas as well as the land.
亨利·亚当斯发现，那是一个非常老派的波士顿婆罗门，在巴黎收集艺术品。亚当斯称他为“令人讨厌的老美国人”，他的儿子甚至孙子都将追随跨越大西洋去法国收集艺术品然后回来的传统，他们可能稍后会在故事中出现，多米尼克。正是如此，他们当然是坐泰坦尼克号回来的，汤姆。所以摩根一直在收集公司。美国钢铁公司是他最成功、最著名的一家。所以美国钢铁公司是1901年的。在同一时间，1901年到1902年，他决定将他的统治范围从陆地扩展到海洋。
And he puts together a huge combine called International Mercantile Marine. And this includes a British company called White Star, a shipping company. And The Economist at the time, like a lot of British publications, was very shocked at this. So Tom, you were saying, and I think quite rightly, that part of the story of the Titanic is the story of the emergence of American capitalism at the expense of British. So The Economist said, to the patriotic Britain, it is not a pleasant thought that the great transatlantic trade is in future to be bossed by a syndicate of American capitalists. And this is what the story of IMM is all about. Although, Dominic, intriguingly in America, because it turns out that ultimately Morgan
他组建了一个名为“国际商业海运公司”（IMM）的庞大联合体。这包括一家名为“白星航运”的英国航运公司。当时的《经济学人》像许多英国出版物一样，对此感到非常震惊。所以汤姆，你刚才说，而且我认为非常正确，泰坦尼克号故事的一部分是美国资本主义以牺牲英国资本主义为代价崛起的历史。所以《经济学人》说，对于爱国的英国人来说，未来的跨大西洋贸易将由一个美国资本家集团来掌控，这不是一个令人愉快的想法。这就是IMM故事的全部内容。虽然，多米尼克，有趣的是在美国，因为事实证明摩根最终
has paid too much for White Star, and for reasons that we'll come to, he is unable to establish a complete monopoly. People in America see this as a triumph for British capitalism. The British have fooled him. Yeah, the British have fooled him, that they've tricked the great master of the universe. And I think that that reflects something about the status of this company, White Star, that it is an absolutely marquee brand, isn't it? It is, because this is the point at which steamships are seen as, you know, like cars or like telephones, electricity. Steamships are part of that world.
为白星航运支付了过高的价格，而且由于我们将要讨论的原因，他无法建立完全的垄断。美国人认为这是英国资本主义的胜利。英国人愚弄了他。是的，英国人愚弄了他，他们欺骗了这位伟大的宇宙大师。我认为这反映了白星航运这家公司的地位，它绝对是一个标志性品牌，不是吗？确实，因为这是蒸汽船被视为像汽车、电话或电力一样的东西的时刻。蒸汽船是那个世界的一部分。
They are embodiments of the sort of exciting modernity of the day. So all of the men who sail on the Titanic, the crewmen, are called sailors. And some of them, the older ones, would probably remember the age of sail, wouldn't they? Because the age of sail in the 1870s or something, if you had taken a ship to New York, it could have been a sailing ship and it could have taken you 40 days. Now it's taking you less than a fortnight and you're doing it by steamship. Steamships have conquered the waves. They are much faster. They are also much safer. So there's an extraordinary statistic in Richard Davenport Hines' book,
它们是那个时代令人兴奋的现代性的化身。所以所有在泰坦尼克号上航行的人，船员，都被称为水手。他们中的一些年长者可能还记得帆船时代，不是吗？因为在1870年代左右的帆船时代，如果你乘船去纽约，那可能是一艘帆船，可能需要40天。现在不到两周就能到达，而且是靠蒸汽船。蒸汽船征服了波浪。它们快得多。它们也安全得多。所以理查德·达文波特·海恩斯的书里有一个惊人的统计数据，
Titanic Lives, an absolutely brilliant book, I have to say, that one in 184 passengers on sailing ships will die making the Atlantic crossing. But on steamships, it's one in 2,000. So in other words, steamships are much, much safer. But steamships are also... Well, they're much faster, aren't they? Also the stat in Richard Davenport Hines' book. In 1872, the average crossing from Liverpool to New York by sailing vessel took 44 days by steamship under a fortnight. And of course, the notion of the blue ribbon, the first ship across the Atlantic becomes something that people on both sides of the Atlantic become obsessed by. Yeah. So steamships to us, they seem old fashioned. At the time, they seem absolutely the Atlantic becomes something that people, you know, on both sides of the Atlantic become obsessed by.
《泰坦尼克号的生活》，我必须说这是一本绝对精彩的书，帆船上每184名乘客中就有一人在横渡大西洋时死亡。但在蒸汽船上，这个比例是两千分之一。换句话说，蒸汽船要安全得多。但蒸汽船也……嗯，它们快得多，不是吗？理查德·达文波特·海恩斯的书中也有这个统计。1872年，从利物浦到纽约的平均航行时间，帆船需要44天，而蒸汽船不到两周。当然，蓝丝带奖，即第一艘横渡大西洋的船，成了大西洋两岸人们痴迷的东西。是的。所以对我们来说，蒸汽船看起来很过时。在当时，它们看起来绝对是……大西洋成了人们痴迷的东西。
So steamships to us, they seem old fashioned. At the time, they seem absolutely thrilling. The Futurist Manifesto by Marinetti. When's that? 1909, something like that. 1908. In the Futurist Manifesto, the world's splendor has been enriched by a new beauty, the beauty of speed. We will sing of the fervid nighttime vibrations of armaments factories and shipyards blazing with violent electric moons, bold steamers sniffing the horizon,
所以对我们来说，蒸汽船看起来很过时。在当时，它们看起来绝对令人兴奋。《未来主义宣言》由马里内蒂所写。那是什么时候？1909年左右吧。1908年。在《未来主义宣言》中，世界的光辉被一种新的美所丰富，那就是速度之美。我们将歌颂军火工厂和造船厂在狂暴的电月亮下闪耀的狂热夜间振动，嗅着地平线的勇敢轮船，
the sleek flight of aircraft whose propellers turn like banners in the wind. So in other words, steamships are part of that world of aircraft. They're incredibly exciting. And speed itself, it's not just convenient, but speed itself is seen as something unbelievably ecstatic, something to be celebrated above all else by the futurists. And so do you think that now the marker of an absolutely cutting edge economy is to have a massive tech company? And today, famously, America has all the tech companies and Europe doesn't have any. But is the white star line a British equivalent of Apple or something. It's a marker of a really, really successful
飞机那像风中旗帜般旋转的螺旋桨的平滑飞行。换句话说，蒸汽船是那个飞机世界的一部分。它们令人难以置信地兴奋。而速度本身，不仅方便，而且速度本身被未来主义者视为一种令人难以置信的狂喜，一种高于一切值得庆祝的东西。所以你认为现在衡量一个绝对尖端经济体的标准是拥有一家大型科技公司吗？今天，众所周知，美国拥有所有的科技公司，而欧洲一家都没有。但白星航运是英国版的苹果吗？它是衡量一家非常、非常成功的
company at the cutting edge of technology. And so that's why the question of who owns it is so potent. Yeah. These steamship companies are seen as emblems of a nation's virility to some extent, aren't they? Yeah. We've come to the Anglo- the anglo-german competition right which is why the ships have to be bigger and bigger and bigger bigger and bigger and faster and faster absolutely absolutely then there's a general obsession with speed davenport hines in his book points out that you know one of the most famous passengers in the titanic john jacob aster was one of the first americans to buy a motor car he had had 18 cars. Some of these American passengers with two surnames rather than a first name and a surname. It's a guy called
处于技术前沿的公司的标志。这就是为什么谁拥有它这个问题如此重要。是的。这些蒸汽船公司在某种程度上被视为一个国家活力的象征，不是吗？是的。我们谈到了英德竞争，这就是为什么船只必须越来越大、越来越大、越来越快、越来越快。绝对是这样。当时人们对速度有一种普遍的痴迷。达文波特·海恩斯在他的书中指出，泰坦尼克号上最著名的乘客之一约翰·雅各布·阿斯特是第一批购买汽车的美国人之一，他拥有18辆车。一些有两个姓氏而不是名字和姓氏的美国乘客。有一个叫
Washington Rubling II who designed a racing car. He's one of the millionaires in the Titanic. Another millionaire in the Titanic, a man called Dickinson Bishop. He has a car waiting for him in New York. The most expensive car in the world, a Losea. He's paid $7,750 for. And there's actually a car on the Titanic, isn't it? There's a Renault. One of the American millionaires takes a car with him. So this worship of technology, machinery, and speed, I mean, it's connected to that
华盛顿·罗布林二世的人，他设计了一辆赛车。他是泰坦尼克号上的百万富翁之一。泰坦尼克号上的另一位百万富翁，一个叫迪金森·毕晓普的人。他在纽约有一辆车等着他。世界上最贵的车，一辆洛齐尔（Lozier）。他花了7750美元。泰坦尼克号上实际上有一辆车，不是吗？有一辆雷诺。其中一位美国百万富翁带了一辆车。所以这种对技术、机械和速度的崇拜，我的意思是，它与
thing that you're talking about, which is the idea of nation's sense of success and virtue and virility being bound up with the ownership of the companies that embody those virtues. Yeah. And so that's why White Star matters. And it's been founded by a man from the Lake District, Dominic. Yeah, Cumbrian. Yeah. Thomas Ismay, who, I mean, he's not highly educated.
你正在谈论的事情有关，即一个国家的成功感、美德和活力与拥有体现这些美德的公司紧密相连的想法。是的。这就是为什么白星航运很重要。而且它是由一个来自湖区的人创立的，多米尼克。是的，坎布里亚人。是的。托马斯·伊斯梅，我的意思是，他没有受过高等教育。
He hasn't been to an expensive public school or any of that stuff, but he's an absolute, dare I say, titan. Yeah, he's a really interesting figure because that earlier generation of kind of the rough-hewn entrepreneurs who've built themselves up from nothing, he bought this shipping firm called Whitestar. And what they were specialising in was shipping people to the goldfields in Australia. Which is a long way away. Yeah, and he apparently, he was playing billions with a bloke, shipping people to the gold fields in Australia. Which is a long way away. Yeah.
他没有上过昂贵的公立学校或任何类似的东西，但他绝对是一个，我敢说，泰坦。是的，他是一个非常有趣的人物，因为那一代白手起家的粗犷企业家买下了这家名为“白星”的航运公司。他们专门从事将人们运送到澳大利亚金矿区的工作。那可是很远的地方。是的，他显然是在和一个人玩数十亿的生意，将人们运送到澳大利亚的金矿区。那可是很远的地方。是的。
And he apparently, he was playing billions with a bloke. And the bloke said, why do you bother doing that? Why don't you ship people to America? It's much closer. And he started to ship people to the United States. And the thing is, he's doing that in 1867, 68, 69, at just the point when the American Civil War has ended. So there's a big demand now.
他显然是在和一个人玩数十亿的生意。那个人说，你为什么要费心做那个？你为什么不把人运到美国去？那近得多。于是他开始把人运往美国。问题是，他在1867、68、69年这样做，正好是美国内战结束的时候。所以现在需求很大。
It's starting to boom. Yeah, it's booming again. People want to go to the United States. Now to do this, he signs a deal with a particular shipyard called Harland and Wolfe in Belfast. They lend him the money to expand his building program to do this on the condition that they will all be built in Belfast and we will come back to Belfast and to Harland and Wolfe. But his particular wheeze, as well as kind of moving to the transatlantic crossing, is to offer people luxury travel. So if you think back, we talked in a previous episode about Dickens crossing the Atlantic to go to America. So he goes on a steamer
它开始繁荣了。是的，它又繁荣了。人们想去美国。为了做到这一点，他与贝尔法斯特的一家名为哈兰德与沃尔夫的造船厂签署了一项协议。他们借钱给他扩大造船计划，条件是所有船只都必须在贝尔法斯特建造。我们将回到贝尔法斯特和哈兰德与沃尔夫。但他特别的妙招，除了转向跨大西洋航线外，就是为人们提供豪华旅行。所以如果你回想一下，我们在之前的一集中谈到过狄更斯横渡大西洋去美国。所以他乘坐的是一艘
that has been built by a rival British company called Cunard. And they are saying, oh, we've got amazing cabins. And Dickens is very, very sniffy about this. So he complains that his luggage could no more be got in at the door of his cabin than a giraffe could be persuaded or forced into a flower pot. So even in the 1840s, luxury is still very, very gruelling. But what Ismay does is really to go in hard and to basically kind of start looking to luxury hotels as a source of inspiration. And so to go on a white star liner, it's not an ordeal. It's a positive pleasure. Yeah. So what they do, it's an unusual example, actually, of a company being incredibly successful by going very, very high end.
由英国竞争对手卡纳德公司建造的轮船。他们说，哦，我们有很棒的客舱。狄更斯对此非常不屑。所以他抱怨说，他的行李根本塞不进客舱门，就像长颈鹿无法被劝说或强行塞进花盆一样。所以即使在1840年代，豪华旅行仍然非常非常折磨人。但伊斯梅所做的是真正下功夫，基本上开始把豪华酒店作为灵感来源。所以乘坐白星航运的班轮，不是一种折磨。而是一种积极的享受。是的。所以他们所做的，实际上是一个公司通过走高端路线而获得巨大成功的不同寻常的例子。
Reassuringly expensive yeah it's antithesis of the sort of the lord sugar for our british listeners or the sort of cut costs drive down your overheads is may doesn't do that at all what is may does is you say he has electric bells he has hot running water in the baths it's a floating hotel yeah and he has a series of ships oceanic is the first one then adriatic britannic you'll see how we're going to get to titanic well they all end in ick don't they coptic ionic doric seasick well no well no not seasick no because you don't have seasick yeah as you say it's a holiday it's a treat to go on a white star yeah crossing and so ismay as you say i mean he's kind of pulled
令人放心地昂贵。是的，这与我们英国听众所知的阿兰·休格（Lord Sugar）那种削减成本、降低开销的做法截然相反。伊斯梅根本不那样做。伊斯梅所做的是，正如你所说，他有电铃，浴室里有热水，这是一个浮动的酒店。是的，他有一系列船只，第一艘是“海洋号”，然后是“亚得里亚号”、“不列颠号”，你会看到我们是如何引出“泰坦尼克号”的。嗯，它们都以“ic”结尾，不是吗？科普特号、爱奥尼亚号、多立克号、晕船号……嗯，不，嗯，不，不是晕船号，因为你不会晕船。是的，正如你所说，这是一次假期，乘坐白星航运横渡大西洋是一种享受。所以伊斯梅，正如你所说，我的意思是，他算是
himself up by his bootstraps and he's very tough, very hard. And in the 1870s, you know, there's a particular crisis that could have derailed the entire company when in 1873, one of his steamships, the Atlantic, runs out of coal on the way to New York. They divert course to go to Halifax to pick up coal and they end up hitting a rock and the lifeboats are swept away 250 lives about a third of the people on board the ship are lost and you know it creates an enormous scandal it could have completely derailed the company it doesn't because ismay is the kind of man who's not going to be diverted by a crisis like that right but tom that's a reminder isn't it that it is a floating hotel these are holidays for some people, not for most people, arrogance, but still a hint of danger in the Atlantic crossing, isn't there? It's not entirely on it. It will be like a hotel and all risk of
白手起家，他非常强硬，非常坚韧。在1870年代，你知道，发生了一场可能使整个公司脱轨的特殊危机，当时在1873年，他的一艘蒸汽船“大西洋号”在去纽约的路上煤炭耗尽。他们改道去哈利法克斯取煤，结果撞上了一块岩石，救生艇被冲走了，250条生命，大约三分之一的船上人员丧生。你知道，这造成了巨大的丑闻，它本可以完全摧毁这家公司。但它没有，因为伊斯梅是那种不会被那样的危机所阻挡的人。但汤姆，这提醒了我们，不是吗？它是一个浮动酒店，对某些人来说是假期，对大多数人来说不是，傲慢，但大西洋航行中仍然有一丝危险，不是吗？它并不完全是。它会像一家酒店，所有的
danger has effectively gone. And this is obviously a massive boom area of development because essentially you can build bigger and bigger ships and you can make them more and more luxurious. And this is why it's a really good business to be in. And so Ismay, looking ahead to the future, he wants to establish a dynasty. He has three sons. Of these three sons, only one develops an interest in the sea. And this is his middle son, Bruce. And Bruce, on one level, is a classic example of what happens when British industrialists become very rich.
危险风险实际上已经消失了。这显然是一个巨大的发展繁荣领域，因为本质上你可以建造越来越大的船，你可以让它们越来越豪华。这就是为什么这是一个非常好的行业。所以伊斯梅展望未来，他想建立一个王朝。他有三个儿子。在这三个儿子中，只有一个对海洋产生了兴趣。这就是他的次子布鲁斯。布鲁斯在某种程度上是英国工业家变得非常有钱后所发生事情的典型例子。
They send their children to private schools where basically the sons are taught to be ashamed of their parents for having the wrong accent, which is what happens. But at the same time, you know, daddy is not interested really in the airs and graces that his young son has been taught. I mean, it's purely a marker of status that he can send him off to private school. What he really wants is a guy who is going to be effective at running the company. And so that is what Bruce does. The other two sons go off and become members of the landed gentry. Bruce Ismay does stay true to the source of his family's wealth. So it's brilliantly summed up by Francis Wilson, who wrote a wonderful book called How to Survive the Tanic or the Sinking of J. Bruce Ismay. She said, Thomas, so Thomas
他们把孩子送到私立学校，在那里儿子们基本上被教导要为父母有错误的口音而感到羞耻，这就是所发生的事情。但与此同时，你知道，爸爸对他的小儿子被教导的那些虚荣心并不真正感兴趣。我的意思是，他能送他去私立学校纯粹是一个地位的标志。他真正想要的是一个能有效经营公司的人。所以这就是布鲁斯所做的。另外两个儿子去成了土地贵族。布鲁斯·伊斯梅确实忠于他家族财富的来源。所以弗朗西斯·威尔逊总结得非常精彩，她写了一本名为《如何在大西洋中幸存或J·布鲁斯·伊斯梅的沉没》的精彩书籍。她说，托马斯，所以托马斯
Ismay, the father was a Victorian, Bruce and Edwardian. The father stood for entrepreneurial strength and imperial greatness, the son for decline. And maybe the kind of symbolic resonance that shadows the whole of this story, Thomas Ismay dies one year before the death of Queen Victoria. It's not just a British event of note. It has international resonance. The Kaiser sends a telegram of condolence to Ismay's widow. All the flags in Liverpool are hung at half mast. And Bruce Ismay takes over. And the first thing he does, Dominic, is to sell the company to J. Pierpoint Morgan. So there's a real succession element to this, isn't there? You mentioned the logan roy comparison so for people who haven't seen the succession is the great great
伊斯梅，父亲是一个维多利亚时代的人，布鲁斯是一个爱德华时代的人。父亲代表了创业力量和帝国伟大，儿子代表了衰落。也许那种笼罩在这个故事中的象征性共鸣是，托马斯·伊斯梅在维多利亚女王去世前一年去世。这不仅仅是一个值得注意的英国事件。它具有国际共鸣。德皇向伊斯梅的遗孀发去了慰问电。利物浦所有的旗帜都降半旗。布鲁斯·伊斯梅接手了。他做的第一件事，多米尼克，就是把公司卖给J·皮尔庞特·摩根。所以这里确实有一个继承的因素，不是吗？你提到了洛根·罗伊的比较，所以对于没看过《继承之战》的人来说，这是以默多克家族为原型的伟大电视连续剧，在那部剧中，有一个由布莱恩·考克斯扮演的凶猛的苏格兰白手起家的人，然后是他的那些无能的儿子和女儿，他们竞争取代他，但永远不会像他那么好，永远不会像他那么渴望，因为他们是在财富中长大的。这就是布鲁斯·伊斯梅的故事，因为他去过哈罗公学，不是吗？他将乘坐泰坦尼克号。他是一个非常高的人。他非常优雅。
tv series model on the murdoch family and in that series there's this sort of ferocious scottish self-made man played by brian cox and then his sort of feckless sons and daughter who are competing to replace him who are never going to be as good, never going to be as hungry because they've been reared amidst wealth. That's the story that Bruce Ismay, because he'd gone to Harrow, hadn't he? He is going to travel on the Titanic. He is a very tall man. He's very polished.
留着下垂的胡子。他很有礼貌。他是绅士的精髓。我的意思是，这就是托马斯·伊斯梅想要的。此外，他将从泰坦尼克号中幸存下来，这将使他声名狼藉。但就目前而言，多米尼克，他为什么要卖掉公司？嗯，基本上是因为摩根的财力比世界上任何人都雄厚，而且为它提供了一笔惊人的钱。
A droopy moustache. He's polite. He's the quintessence of a gentleman. I mean, that's what Thomas Ismay wanted. Also, he is going to survive the Titanic, and this will make him notorious. But just for now, Dominic, why does he want to sell the company? Well, basically, because Morgan has deeper pockets than anyone in the world and is offering him an obscene amount of money for it.
是的。所以我们谈到了IMM的成立。摩根基本上支付了他白星航运收益价值的10倍，外加700万美元的现金溢价。所以他最终以3500万美元买下了它。现在这里有点猫腻，不是吗？因为船只仍然悬挂英国国旗。它们仍然有英国船员。而伊斯梅作为交易的一部分，将继续在IMM联合体内经营白星航运。这就是他这样做的原因。但这很像英国目前对科技公司在纽约证券交易所上市而不是在伦敦上市的焦虑。有一种感觉，即声望公司、尖端公司正在被美国资本主义的力量所接管。还有一个额外的焦虑是，船只被需要用来运送军队。所以托马斯·伊斯梅在布尔战争期间曾把他的船借给英国政府运送军队。对于这可能会发生什么，有一种真正的焦虑感。所以英国政府随后介入，给了卡纳德公司一大笔补贴。所以卡纳德是英国的竞争对手，有效地与这个
Yes. So we talked about the foundation of IMM. Morgan basically pays him 10 times the value of White Star's earnings, plus a premium of $7 million in cash. So he ends up buying it for $35 million. Now there's a bit of a fudge, isn't there? Because the ships will still have a British flag. They'll still have British crews. And Ismay, as part of the deal, will carry on running White Star within the IMM combine. So that's why he does it. But it's very like kind of anxieties in Britain at the moment about tech companies kind of listing themselves on the New York Stock Exchange rather than in London. There's that kind of feeling that prestige companies, cutting edge companies are being taken over by the might of American capitalism. And an additional anxiety is that ships are needed to transport troops. So Thomas Ismay had loaned his ships to the British government during the Boer War to transport troops. And there's a real feeling of anxiety about what this might be. And so the British government then lean in and they give Cunard a massive bung. So Cunard is the rival British company effectively to compete with this
摩根正在建立的潜在垄断竞争。而且因为摩根买不下卡纳德，这意味着他实际上并没有建立垄断。因此，他陷入了他不想拥有的那种竞争中。是的。因为所有这些20世纪初的美国资本家的全部目的，正如你所说，是建立完全的市场主导地位，然后基本上固定价格以适应他们自己。他不能这样做，部分是因为英国政府在资助卡纳德作为竞争对手，但也因为，汤姆，其他人已经进入了这个故事。
would-be monopoly that Morgan is setting up. And because Morgan cannot buy Cunard, it means that he doesn't actually establish a monopoly. And so therefore he is embroiled in exactly the kind of competition that he didn't want to have. Yes. Because the whole point with all of these American capitalists at the beginning of the 1900s is, as you say, to establish complete market dominance and then to basically fix the prices to suit themselves. He can't do this partly because the British government is sponsoring Cunard as a competitor, but also because, Tom, some other people have entered the story.
德国人。德国人。所以德国人出现了，他们有两家大公司。一家叫汉堡-美洲航运公司，另一家叫北德意志劳埃德航运公司。当然，1890年代、1900年代的故事是德国在科学、工程等各个领域取得巨大增长的故事。造船业是德国取得巨大增长的领域之一。所以此时，1903年，也就是IMM和白星航运在皮尔庞特·摩根旗帜下存在的第一年，
The Germans. The Germans. So the Germans have turned up and they have two big companies. One is called Hamburg America and the other is Norddeutsche Lloyd. And of course, the story of the 1890s, 1900s is one of tremendous German growth in all kinds of areas, science, engineering, and so on. Shipbuilding is one of tremendous German growth in all kinds of areas, science, engineering, and so on. Shipbuilding is one of these things. So that at this point, 1903, which is the first full year of the existence of IMM and the existence of White Star under Pierpont Morgan's banner,
世界上最快的四艘船都是德国的。它们都有这些非常德国化的爱国名字。“皇帝号”、“祖国号”、“俾斯麦号”。是的。所以白星航运一直是设定豪华标准的标杆。但在1903年，汉堡-美洲航运公司有一艘名为“美国号”的船，是由设计伦敦丽思卡尔顿酒店的人设计的。他们有丽思卡尔顿的标准。这超出了白星航运曾经做过的任何事情。现在英国公司必须反击。所以首先，卡纳德建造了三艘非常著名的船，“毛里塔尼亚号”、“阿奎塔尼亚号”和“卢西塔尼亚号”。
the four fastest ships in the world are all German. And they all have these very Germanic patriotic names. Imperator. Waterland. Bismarck. Yes. So White Star had always been the company that set the standard for luxury. But Hamburg America in 1903 have a ship called America that has been designed by the people who designed the Ritz-Carlton hotels in London. And they have Ritz-Carlton standards. And this is beyond anything that White Star have ever done. And now the British companies have to fight back. So first of all, Cunard build three very famous ships, the Mauritania, the Aquitania, and the Lusitania.
当然，这就是你提到的大战联系，其中两艘在1907年进行了处女航，这当然给摩根和他的联合体带来了更大的压力。是的。所以克林顿·道金斯，我们提到的那个称他为“泰坦尼克”的人，我的意思是，他说“威胁要淹没我们的是这种为造船而背负的巨大债务，我不觉得我们没有在大西洋上投入比它所能承受的更多的巨轮。”所以航运业存在巨大的产能过剩，但他们别无选择，只能与卡纳德和德国公司竞争。当然，你知道，白星航运的声誉是绝对的豪华。所以这基本上就是泰坦尼克号及其两艘姊妹船的构想来源。正是如此。
Of course, there's your Great War connection, two of which make their maiden voyages in 1907 that of course then puts greater pressure on morgan and his combine yeah so clinton dawkins who we mentioned the guy who describes him as titanic i mean he says what threatens to swamp us is this monstrous indebtedness for shipbuilding and i don't feel satisfied that we're not putting more big ships into the atlantic than it can. So there is massive overcapacity in the shipping, but they have no choice but to compete with Cunard and with the German firms. And of course, you know, the White Star reputation is for absolute luxury. And so that basically is where the idea for the Titanic and its two sister ships comes from. Exactly. the Titanic and its two sister ships comes from. So Ismay gets together with a guy who we'll come to in a little bit called Lord Pirrie.
泰坦尼克号及其两艘姊妹船的构想来源。所以伊斯梅和我们稍后会提到的一个叫皮里勋爵的人聚在一起。
Lord Pirrie is the head of the shipyards, Harland and Wolfe in Belfast. And Ismay says, listen, what we could do is we could just go bigger. And better. I mean, just go bigger than Cunard, bigger than the Germans. And again, let's think about three ships and they're going to call them the Olympic, the Britannic, and the Titanic. And these three ships will allow us to recapture the momentum and the reputation, which we need to justify our existence as part of the J.B. Morgan business empire that has been created. And that effectively, Tom, I mean, these are the origins of the Titanic, the financial world of the 1900s, the Anglo-German competition, the new Anglo-American kind of business relationship with all of its anxieties, the excitement of the age of steam and speed and technology. And also, of course, something we'll come to later on, which is the boom in emigration
皮里勋爵是贝尔法斯特哈兰德与沃尔夫造船厂的负责人。伊斯梅说，听着，我们可以做的是我们只是造得更大。更好。我的意思是，比卡纳德更大，比德国人更大。再说一次，让我们考虑三艘船，我们要把它们命名为“奥林匹克号”、“不列颠号”和“泰坦尼克号”。这三艘船将使我们能够夺回动力和声誉，我们需要证明我们作为J.P.摩根商业帝国一部分的存在。这实际上，汤姆，我的意思是，这就是泰坦尼克号的起源，1900年代的金融世界，英德竞争，新的英美商业关系及其所有的焦虑，蒸汽、速度和技术的时代带来的兴奋。当然，还有我们稍后会谈到的，即移民到美国的繁荣，
to the United States, because that's, of course, what's driving so much of this, that so many people want to start lives in the new world. But Dominic, this is the transatlantic context, but these ships in the Titanic, the Olympic and the Britannic have to be built somewhere. And it's a very specific place. It's Belfast in the north of Ireland. And I think we should take a break now. And when we come back, let's look at the specific Belfast context for the making of this extraordinary ship.
因为这当然是推动这一切的动力，有那么多人想在新世界开始生活。但多米尼克，这是跨大西洋的背景，但泰坦尼克号、奥林匹克号和不列颠号必须在某个地方建造。这是一个非常具体的地方。它是爱尔兰北部的贝尔法斯特。我想我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们看看制造这艘非凡船只的具体贝尔法斯特背景。
Brilliant. So we'll be talking about Belfast after the break. Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. dot com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. We are looking at the story of the Titanic. And in the first half, we were exploring the background to the building of this colossal ship in Anglo-American relations, the transatlantic world of the early 20th century. But Dominic, now we want to zoom in on a particular place, don't we? Which is Belfast. Because Belfast is where the Titanic will be built. So let's do it, Tom, as we did the first half. Let's do it through a particular character,
太棒了。休息过后，我们将讨论贝尔法斯特。海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐即一切》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的来源，在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想收听无广告内容、获得额外剧集并优先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。就是 therestisentertainment.com。点 com。你好，欢迎回到《历史即一切》。我们正在研究泰坦尼克号的故事。在上半部分，我们探讨了这艘巨轮建造的背景，以及20世纪初跨大西洋世界的英美关系。但是多米尼克，现在我们要聚焦于一个特定的地方，对吧？那就是贝尔法斯特。因为泰坦尼克号就是在贝尔法斯特建造的。那么汤姆，让我们像上半部分那样，通过一个特定的人物来讲述吧，
one of the three individuals that are really responsible for the ship. And this is this guy called William Pirrie, the first Viscount Pirrie. So he was the person that Bruce Ismay was talking to at the end of the first half about how they were going to compete with the Germans and with Cunard. Let's build bigger and better. Pirrie is the head of the Harland and Wolfe shipyard in Belfast, Belfast's most famous employer. Pirrie, again, is a transatlantic character who was born in Quebec City in 1847. His father died in New York two years later, and his mother brings him back. They're a family from the north of Ireland, Northern Ireland, as we would call it now, though, of course, then the state, as it were, of Northern Ireland didn't exist as a separate state.
也就是真正对这艘船负责的三个人之一。这个人叫威廉·皮里，第一代皮里子爵。他就是布鲁斯·伊斯梅在上半部分结尾时谈论的对象，讨论他们将如何与德国人和卡纳德航运公司竞争。让我们建造更大更好的船。皮里是贝尔法斯特哈兰德与沃尔夫造船厂的负责人，这是贝尔法斯特最著名的雇主。皮里同样是一个跨大西洋的人物，他于1847年出生在魁北克市。他的父亲两年后在纽约去世，母亲把他带了回来。他们是来自爱尔兰北部，也就是我们现在所说的北爱尔兰的家庭，尽管当时北爱尔兰作为一个独立的国家并不存在。
His mum brings him back to County Down. He goes to this very well-known private grammar school in Belfast, the Royal Belfast Academical Institution, William Pirrie, and he joins Harland and Wolfe, the shipyards, as an apprentice when he is 15 years old. Now, Harland and Wolfe, their foundation is 1859 when it's bought by a guy called Edward Harland and he goes into partnership with a man called Gustav Wulf. Astonishing. Who'd have guessed it? And their business model is that they drum up custom from often foreign shipowning companies, and they do deals with them, and they will build the ships right there in Belfast. Lord Pirrie, who works his way up, is a brilliant kind of salesman. He will tour the land, making small talk with millionaires and persuading them, come to Belfast, we will build
他母亲把他带回了唐郡。他进入了贝尔法斯特一所非常著名的私立文法学校——贝尔法斯特皇家学院，威廉·皮里在15岁时以学徒身份加入了哈兰德与沃尔夫造船厂。哈兰德与沃尔夫造船厂成立于1859年，当时由爱德华·哈兰德买下，并与古斯塔夫·沃尔夫合伙。令人惊讶。谁能想到呢？他们的商业模式是从外国船运公司那里招揽生意，与他们达成协议，然后就在贝尔法斯特建造这些船只。皮里勋爵通过努力工作晋升，是一位出色的推销员。他会巡回各地，与百万富翁们闲聊，说服他们来到贝尔法斯特，我们将为您建造
your ship for you. Richard Davenport Hines describes him as, he says, a small masterful man with intrepid nerves and unshakable self-confidence. He thought nothing of removing grit from one of his shipyard workers' eyes with the blade of a knife. Wow. Which, of all the details of the Titanic story, is the one I find most terrifying. Yeah. Quite honestly.
您的船。理查德·达文波特·海恩斯这样描述他：他说，这是一个身材矮小、精明强干、胆识过人且自信心不可动摇的人。他甚至会用刀片从造船厂工人的眼睛里剔除沙砾。哇。在泰坦尼克号故事的所有细节中，这是我发现最可怕的一个。是的。老实说。
So he is a workaholic, Pirri. He speaks with a very strong Belfast accent, which at the time people regard as reassuring. You know, it's not too smooth. Kind of like Scottish bank managers. Yeah, absolutely. He said that he has a magic and he will charm orders out of customers. And thanks to Piri's salesmanship, Harland & Wolfe becomes by far the biggest shipbuilder in the world by the end of 1910, when it is building the Titanic and the Titanic class ships. Harland & Wolfe employs more than 11,000 people and it absolutely dominates the landscape of Belfast.
所以皮里是个工作狂。他说话带着浓重的贝尔法斯特口音，当时人们认为这种口音很让人放心。你知道，它不会太圆滑。有点像苏格兰的银行经理。是的，绝对是。他说他有一种魔力，能从客户那里吸引订单。多亏了皮里的推销能力，到1910年底，当哈兰德与沃尔夫造船厂正在建造泰坦尼克号及其同级船只时，它已成为世界上规模最大的造船厂。哈兰德与沃尔夫雇佣了超过11,000人，绝对主导了贝尔法斯特的景观。
But also, I think, the world's imagination because the world is obsessed with steamships and with ships and with speed. And Harland & Wolfe is the company. There's a brilliant comment on him by W.T. Stead, a big newspaper man who I think we've mentioned before. He's the guy who basically whips up the campaign to get General Gordon sent to the Sudan and all kinds of things. And he will feature again later in this story. And he said of Piri that he is the greatest ship
但我认为，它也主导了世界的想象力，因为世界对蒸汽船、船舶和速度着迷。而哈兰德与沃尔夫就是那家公司。W.T.斯特德对他的评价非常精彩，他是一位大报业巨头，我想我们之前提到过。他基本上就是那个煽动运动派遣戈登将军去苏丹等等事情的人。他稍后还会出现在这个故事中。他说皮里是世界上有史以来最伟大的造船
builder the world has ever seen. He has built more ships and bigger ships than any man since the days of Noah. Not only does he build them, he owns them, directs them, controls them on all the seas of the world. So there's a sense in which Piri is kind of being promoted as a kind of Irish equivalent of the great capitalists of Gilded Age America, do you think? Yeah, I totally think that. In fact, while you were reading that, I was just thinking, this is an age, isn't it, that worships great men. Yeah, absolutely. In a way that would not be the case today.
家。自诺亚时代以来，他建造的船只数量和规模都超过了任何人。他不仅建造它们，还拥有它们、指导它们、控制着世界上所有的海洋。所以，你认为皮里在某种程度上被宣传为镀金时代美国伟大资本家的爱尔兰版本吗？是的，我完全这么认为。事实上，当你读那段话时，我正在想，这是一个崇拜伟人的时代，不是吗？是的，绝对是。以一种今天不会有的方式。
It doesn't look to diminish greatness as we do. Our instinct is to undercut and to say of the tech billionaires, they're very annoying. They have ridiculous opinions. You know, all of this sort of stuff. That's our instinct. Theirs is to magnify. Well, not everybody. I mean, as we will see, there's quite a lot of subterranean hostility
它不像我们今天这样试图贬低伟大。我们的本能是拆台，说科技亿万富翁们很烦人。他们有荒谬的观点。你知道，诸如此类。这是我们的本能。而他们的是去放大。嗯，并不是所有人。我的意思是，正如我们将看到的，他们背后有相当多的地下敌意
to them, but yes. But W.T. Stead, as you said, he is by far the most influential newspaper man of the day. I mean, he is somebody who sets the tone of kind of populist conversation and he likes to inflate. The Edwardians do like to inflate. There is a sort of grandiosity about Edwardian culture, I think. Right. There's an obsession with the Titanic. Yeah, exactly that. Which is why the name is so resonant, isn't it? Exactly. Exactly. So Pirri, he becomes Lord Mayor of Belfast. He's Lord Mayor of Belfast in the Jubilee year of 1897. He buys a succession of great kind of mansions in Belfast, in Belgravia,
，但确实如此。但正如你所说，W.T.斯特德是当时最有影响力的报人。我的意思是，他是一个定下民粹主义对话基调的人，他喜欢夸大。爱德华时代的人确实喜欢夸大。我认为爱德华时代的文化有一种宏大感。没错。有一种对泰坦尼克号的痴迷。是的，正是如此。这就是为什么这个名字如此响亮，不是吗？正是如此。正是如此。所以皮里成为了贝尔法斯特市长。他在1897年的禧年担任贝尔法斯特市长。他在贝尔法斯特、伦敦的贝尔格莱维亚区购买了一连串宏伟的豪宅，
in London. He has a country house in Surrey, I think it is. He wants to go into politics. So he really wants to become the unionist MP for South Belfast. But interestingly, he is rejected by the party hierarchy because Tom is a supporter of home rule for Ireland. Right. So this plunges us back into a topic that we did last year, isn't it? Which is the tortured politics of Ireland and its relations to Great Britain in this period. Yeah, of course. And this is a really, really fascinating, a richly fascinating thread that runs through the story of the Titanic. I mean, Lord Pirrie actually ends up, because he wants to get ahead in politics, he can't do it with the Unionist party. He ends up
他在萨里郡有一座乡村别墅，我想是这样。他想进入政界。所以他真的很想成为南贝尔法斯特的统一党议员。但有趣的是，他被党内高层拒绝了，因为汤姆是爱尔兰自治的支持者。没错。所以这又把我们带回了我们去年讨论过的话题，不是吗？也就是爱尔兰及其在这一时期与英国关系的痛苦政治。是的，当然。这是一个贯穿泰坦尼克号故事的非常、非常迷人且丰富的线索。我的意思是，皮里勋爵最终，因为他想在政治上取得进展，他无法通过统一党实现。他最终
doing it with the Liberals. And the Liberals, the party of Gladstone, the party of Asquith, very much a friend of the rest of history, Tom, this is the party that within Ireland, Catholic Ireland, for home rule, great opposition and antipathy to it among Protestants in Ireland. Who are very much centred in Northern Ireland and specifically in Belfast. Exactly. The Titanic is against that background. So just on Belfast, Belfast in 1912 is by far the biggest and richest and most industrially important city in Ireland. You said it plunges us back into the world of the Irish episodes we did last year. So our guest in some of those episodes, Paul Rouse from University College Dublin, he wrote a thing about Belfast in 1912 for the, I think it was the Irish National Archives or something like that, a big thing about the world of Ireland in the beginning of the 20th century.
通过自由党实现了。自由党，格莱斯顿的党，阿斯奎斯的党，汤姆，这是《历史即一切》的老朋友，这是在爱尔兰内部，天主教爱尔兰，支持自治的党派，在爱尔兰的新教徒中对此有巨大的反对和反感。他们主要集中在北爱尔兰，特别是贝尔法斯特。没错。泰坦尼克号就是在这样的背景下诞生的。所以关于贝尔法斯特，1912年的贝尔法斯特是爱尔兰最大、最富有、工业上最重要的城市。你说它把我们带回了我们去年做的爱尔兰剧集的世界。所以我们在其中一些剧集中的嘉宾，来自都柏林大学学院的保罗·劳斯，他为爱尔兰国家档案馆写了一篇关于1912年贝尔法斯特的文章，关于20世纪初爱尔兰世界的大事。
There's a line in that, it says, Belfast was a place unlike any other in Ireland. Wealth in Dublin and in other Irish cities was usually rooted in trade, in land or in lineage. Wealth in Belfast was the product of industry. So it makes, Belfast, it's a city that makes things, it makes cigarettes, it makes cars, it makes linen, especially more linen than anywhere else on earth. And Dominic, do you know what is brilliant on this? It's the Titanic Museum. Oh, right. Yeah. In Belfast, in what was the Harland and Wolfe shipyards. It's a wonderful museum. They have a brilliant section on this, all the kind of the clamor and the noiseyards it's a wonderful museum they have a brilliant section on this
里面有一行字说，贝尔法斯特是爱尔兰一个与众不同的地方。都柏林和其他爱尔兰城市的财富通常植根于贸易、土地或血统。贝尔法斯特的财富是工业的产物。所以，贝尔法斯特是一个制造东西的城市，它制造香烟、汽车、亚麻，尤其是亚麻，比地球上任何地方都多。多米尼克，你知道关于这个最棒的是什么吗？是泰坦尼克号博物馆。哦，对。是的。在贝尔法斯特，就在曾经的哈兰德与沃尔夫造船厂旧址。这是一个很棒的博物馆。他们有一个关于这个的精彩部分，所有的喧嚣和噪音，这是一个很棒的博物馆，他们有一个关于这个的精彩部分
all the kind of the clamor and the noise they evoke it very very powerfully so uh just a few details that i garnered from that they boasted belfast rope works which was the largest rope maker in the world and they had sirocco works which was the world's leading fan and ventilation manufacturer and both of these of course supplied lots of material to the Titanic. Of course, yeah. So Sirocco Works supplied 75 fans to the Titanic. So I'm guessing that's another reason why it's such a centre of shipbuilding, is that basically all the kind of raw materials that you need to build a huge ship are, you know, they're not just in the shipyards, but scattered around in the companies that dominate the industry of Belfast.
所有那种喧嚣和噪音，他们非常有力地唤起了那种感觉。所以，我从那里收集到的一些细节，他们吹嘘贝尔法斯特绳索厂是世界上最大的绳索制造商，他们还有西罗科工厂，是世界领先的风扇和通风设备制造商，当然，这两者都为泰坦尼克号提供了大量材料。当然，是的。所以西罗科工厂为泰坦尼克号提供了75台风扇。所以我猜这就是它成为造船中心的原因之一，基本上所有建造巨轮所需的原材料，你知道，它们不仅在造船厂里，而且散布在主导贝尔法斯特工业的公司中。
Yeah. So Belfast is more akin in many ways to a sort of Northern or Midlands British industrial city than it is with Irish cities, you know, Cork, Dublin, Limerick and so on further South. So actually there's a wonderful quotation in Richard Davenport Hines' book from an Edwardian visitor who comes from the South of Ireland. And he goes to Belfast, and he's really struck by how different it is. He says, I saw churches of all denominations, Freemason and Orange lodges, wide streets, towering smokestacks, huge factories, crowded traffic. And out of the water, beyond the custom house, dimly seen through smoke and mist rose some huge shapeless thing which i found to be a shipbuilding yard wherein 10 000 men were hammering iron and steel into
是的。所以贝尔法斯特在许多方面更像是一个英国北部或中部的工业城市，而不是像科克、都柏林、利默里克等爱尔兰南部城市。事实上，理查德·达文波特·海恩斯的书中有一段来自爱尔兰南部爱德华时代游客的精彩引语。他去了贝尔法斯特，被它的不同所震撼。他说，我看到了各种教派的教堂、共济会和奥兰治会所、宽阔的街道、高耸的烟囱、巨大的工厂、拥挤的交通。在海关大楼之外的水面上，透过烟雾和薄雾隐约可见一些巨大的无形之物，我发现那是一个造船厂，里面有10,000人在把铁和钢锤打成
great ocean liners the noise of wheels and hoofs and cranks and spindles and steam hammers filled my ears and made my head ache so that's the the way that mid-Victorians talked about Birmingham or Manchester or something. And this is the way that people in Ireland talk about Belfast. It's this terrifying temple to industrial modernity. I guess one thing that Belfast has that most industrial cities, although not all, I mean, things Glasgow and Liverpool, but most industrial cities in Britain don't, is a very, very sharp sectarian divide. It does. Yeah. So Paul Rouse gives in his thing, Belfast has a pub for every 300 people. But of course, what pub you go to is determined by your religion in Belfast. So Belfast had been
伟大的远洋客轮，车轮、蹄声、曲柄、主轴和蒸汽锤的声音充斥着我的耳朵，让我的头痛欲裂。所以这就是维多利亚时代中期人们谈论伯明翰或曼彻斯特的方式。而这就是爱尔兰人谈论贝尔法斯特的方式。这是一个令人恐惧的工业现代性神殿。我想贝尔法斯特拥有大多数工业城市（虽然不是全部，比如格拉斯哥和利物浦，但英国大多数工业城市没有）所具备的一点，就是非常、非常尖锐的宗派分歧。确实。是的。所以保罗·劳斯在他的文章中提到，贝尔法斯特每300人就有一家酒吧。但当然，你去哪家酒吧是由你在贝尔法斯特的宗教信仰决定的。所以贝尔法斯特一直
founded largely Scottish and English Presbyterians in the 1600s, 1603, I think it is. But over time, as has happened with so many industrial cities all over Europe, not just in Britain, but in the United States, what has happened is it has absorbed migrants from the countryside who tend to be Catholic. So in other words, Irish Catholics. So by 1911, the sort of breakdown based on confessionalism is 34 of the people of belfast are presbyterians 30 of them are church of ireland seven percent of
主要由苏格兰和英国长老会教徒在1600年代，我想是1603年建立的。但随着时间的推移，正如欧洲各地，不仅是英国，还有美国许多工业城市所发生的那样，它吸收了来自农村的移民，他们往往是天主教徒。换句话说，爱尔兰天主教徒。所以到1911年，基于教派的构成是：34%的贝尔法斯特人是长老会教徒，30%是爱尔兰教会成员，7%
them are methodists so those are the protestants and then you have the catholics which is 24 and there is absolutely no love lost between them. Well, Dominic, you did mention the pubs. Yeah. The most beautiful Belfast pub, The Crown, which is opposite the Europa Hotel, which in the Troubles was always being bombed, and has kind of beautiful compartments that the ladies would sit in. You can still sit in them now. And this reputedly was owned by a Protestant and a Catholic. And the Protestant husband said that we would call it the crown. And the Catholic wife said,
是卫理公会教徒，所以这些是新教徒，然后是天主教徒，占24%，他们之间完全没有爱。嗯，多米尼克，你确实提到了酒吧。是的。贝尔法斯特最美丽的酒吧，皇冠酒吧，就在欧罗巴酒店对面，在北爱尔兰问题时期总是被炸，它有那种女士们会坐的漂亮隔间。你现在仍然可以坐在里面。据说这是一家由新教徒和天主教徒共同拥有的酒吧。新教徒丈夫说我们要叫它皇冠。天主教妻子说，
all right, but we're going to put the image of the crown on the doorway so that everyone will trample it as they walk in. I mean, that's what I was told when I was there. I don't know whether that's true, but it's a kind of nice example of how, you know, maybe that's the way that you get both Protestants and Catholics into a pub.
好吧，但我们要把皇冠的图案放在门口，这样每个人走进去时都会践踏它。我的意思是，我在那里时有人这么告诉我。我不知道这是否属实，但这是一种很好的例子，说明也许这就是让新教徒和天主教徒都进入酒吧的方式。
Right. I mean, there's another visitor, 1907. Belfast hums with industry and calls itself progressive. Yet underlying all this commercialism, all this thrift, all this cult of the main chance, there is a cast iron bigotry, a cruel, corroding, unfathomable, ferocious sectarian rancour. And Dominic, that ferocious sectarian rancour, I mean, that is very evident in the Harland and Wolfe shipyards, isn't it? Because they are overwhelmingly Protestant, the people who work there. a furnace by Protestant workers in the shipyard until other Catholics with sledgehammers piled in to rescue him, threatening to kind of smash these guys' skulls to pieces. And this story was contested. So some people said, oh, this is totally not true. This is invented. But the very fact that
没错。我的意思是，还有另一位1907年的游客说：贝尔法斯特充满了工业气息，自称进步。然而，在所有这些商业主义、所有这些节俭、所有这些投机取巧的崇拜之下，有一种铁一般的偏执，一种残酷、腐蚀、深不可测、凶猛的宗派仇恨。多米尼克，那种凶猛的宗派仇恨，我的意思是，在哈兰德与沃尔夫造船厂非常明显，不是吗？因为在那里工作的人绝大多数是新教徒。新教工人在造船厂里用熔炉，直到其他天主教徒拿着大锤冲进来救他，威胁要砸碎这些家伙的头骨。这个故事是有争议的。所以有些人说，哦，这完全不是真的。这是编造的。但事实上
such stories were told tells you about the rancor, as it were. So there are riots in Belfast in 1909. There are more riots in 1911 and in 1912, as the two communities turn on each other. Protestants, obviously, the overwhelming majority, they hold the levers of power. But the talk of Home Rule is simmering the whole time. And they are terrified that they will be absorbed into a Catholic-dominated home rule island, which is the absolute last thing they want. And so all the time, without going back to some of our favourite Reston's History metaphors, the temperature is rising, Tom. Yes, the lava is bubbling. It is indeed. Waiting to erupt. I mean, the shipyards do seem to have been places where casual violence was kind of expected. Because another intriguing detail that I learned from visiting the museum was that the foreman
这样的故事被讲述出来，就说明了那种仇恨。所以1909年贝尔法斯特发生了骚乱。1911年和1912年又发生了更多骚乱，因为两个社区互相攻击。新教徒显然是绝大多数，他们掌握着权力杠杆。但关于自治的讨论一直在酝酿。他们非常害怕自己会被并入一个天主教主导的自治岛屿，这是他们最不想看到的事情。所以一直以来，如果不回到我们最喜欢的《历史即一切》的隐喻，温度正在升高，汤姆。是的，熔岩正在冒泡。确实如此。等待喷发。我的意思是，造船厂似乎确实是那种预料到会发生随意暴力的地方。因为我从参观博物馆中学到的另一个有趣的细节是，工头
would wear bowler hats, partly as a symbol of status, but also they would be kind of lead-lined. Like our jobs hat. Yeah, in case a riveter would drop something on their heads. So there were clearly class tensions as well as sectarian tensions. But I guess the bowler hat also, I mean, it's the symbol of the Orange Order, isn't it? It's a kind of visual signifier of that. So again, the kind of class and religion is, I mean, it seems to have been a very potent factor in the shipyards that are building the Titanic.
会戴圆顶硬礼帽，部分是作为地位的象征，但也因为它们是铅衬里的。就像我们的工作帽。是的，以防铆工把东西掉在他们头上。所以显然存在阶级紧张和宗派紧张。但我猜圆顶硬礼帽也是奥兰治会的象征，不是吗？这是一种视觉上的标志。所以再次，阶级和宗教似乎是建造泰坦尼克号的造船厂中一个非常强有力的因素。
Yeah. The Orange Order, which commemorates the victory of William of Orange over James II in 1690, the triumph of Protestantism over Catholicism, that is very strong in the Harland and Wolfe shipyards. So as you say, those are these four men with their bowler hats, will be prominent figures in the Orange Order. Now, Lord Pirrie, interestingly, it's so interesting that he has set himself apart from that by backing Home Rule. And of course, as the temperature does rise, his support for Home Rule becomes ever more controversial. And he's shunned by Belfast Protestant establishment. They see him as a quizling, as somebody who's jumped into bed
是的。纪念1690年威廉三世战胜詹姆斯二世、新教战胜天主教的奥兰治会，在哈兰德与沃尔夫造船厂非常强大。所以正如你所说，那些戴着圆顶硬礼帽的工头，将是奥兰治会的杰出人物。现在，皮里勋爵，有趣的是，他通过支持自治将自己与此区分开来，这非常有趣。当然，随着温度升高，他对自治的支持变得越来越有争议。他被贝尔法斯特的新教建制派所排斥。他们视他为卖国贼，视他为跳上床的人
with the illegitimate liberals over in London, who are trying to, as they say, give their country away to the Pope. Right. Okay. So Dominic, that's the background to the building of this ship, the Titanic. We've looked at the transatlantic context. We've looked at the specific context of the city and the shipyard in which it is built. And I think in our next episode, let's look at the Titanic itself. Let's look at why it gets the name it does, which it is built. And I think in our next episode, let's look at the Titanic itself. Let's look at why it gets the name it does, how it's built, the fittings, the crew, and we'll get it out onto the ocean,
与伦敦那些非法的自由党人勾结，他们正如他们所说，试图把他们的国家交给教皇。没错。好的。所以多米尼克，这就是建造泰坦尼克号这艘船的背景。我们看了跨大西洋的背景。我们看了它建造所在的城市和造船厂的具体背景。我想在我们的下一集中，让我们看看泰坦尼克号本身。让我们看看它为什么叫这个名字，它是如何建造的，配件，船员，我们将把它带到海洋上，
ready for its maiden and what will prove its final voyage. Jolly good. We will see you next time. Now, we love a voyage and the rest is history, Tom, don't we? I see us very much as the Captain Smith and the Charles Lightoller. We are. We are. And we'd like to
准备好它的处女航，也将证明是它的最后一次航行。太好了。我们下次见。现在，我们热爱航行，《历史即一切》，汤姆，不是吗？我非常把我们看作是史密斯船长和查尔斯·莱托勒。我们是。我们是。我们想
see ourselves as the owner of the great ship that transports people. And we offer births, don't we, on this ship? We do. We love our crew. Now, if you are a member of the Rest is History crew, that club, you can sign up at therestishistory.com. You can listen to all our Titanic episodes instantly. No need to wait. No need for the Atlantic crossing. So don't delay.
把自己看作是运送人们的巨轮的主人。我们提供铺位，不是吗，在这艘船上？我们提供。我们爱我们的船员。现在，如果您是《历史即一切》船员的一员，那个俱乐部，您可以在 therestishistory.com 注册。您可以立即收听我们所有的泰坦尼克号剧集。无需等待。无需横渡大西洋。所以不要拖延。
Head to that website, therestishistory.com. Lift yourselves out of steerage and we will see you next time for the building of the Titanic. Then we'll get into the crews, the passengers. And then, minute by minute, we will tell the story of its voyage and the unfolding disaster. Its rendezvous with an iceberg. So, on that note, bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman
前往那个网站，therestishistory.com。把自己从三等舱中提升出来，我们下次见，讨论泰坦尼克号的建造。然后我们将进入船员、乘客。然后，我们将逐分钟讲述它的航行故事和展开的灾难。它与冰山的相遇。所以，以此为注，再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼
and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain
我们共同主持《娱乐即一切》，这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的来源，在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开幕布
on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to
关于娱乐，我们告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想收听无广告内容、获得额外剧集并优先购买现场演出门票，请前往
therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
therestisentertainment.com 本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。